hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma I know you
missed this site hmm that's good okay
but anyway I need to move on and find
out how to get out of here so with that
being said I decided not to actually
find out what I'm supposed to do besides
all this stop it it's against the Lord
yeah
no sudden oh do anything for you how
about I pull this out huh oh you're a
fighter huh
don't
did you tell me not to do that we all
need it sure what did I just do whoa
whoa whoa whoa Oh what did I do that was
weird
Oh gah gah - you okay oh I see I need to
play a game boop-boop this game is not
fun okay I get it
OOP no hang on let me goddamn it let me
I know what I need
wait oh oh hey okay I get it now I did
it I did this thing Jesus
ah
well alright then good for me I killed
something and I started at the power
good for me everything seems to be off
Lisbon Portugal Cadiz Spain okay so
we're on earth what's happening
hello is there anyone there yes Hey can
you hear me you hear you
uh I'm salat what's going on I I have no
idea I just sort of woke up here in a
room right now uh it was it's like a
seat with a helmet is all right
what's your name I'm Simon Jarrett and
what are you where are you now some
place dealing with electrical power on
that Shore if it's a plant or a
transformer yeah you're probably in a
filler plant somewhere you want to go
upstairs to the comm center it's the
room with the dome ceiling Hey look look
this place is not him there's something
seriously wrong here
hello I'm sorry I didn't catch that we
lost another relay but listen head for
the comm center upstairs I'll wait here
okay thank you thank you lady if you're
even real hey maybe I'm not real hey
that's unnecessary I got an achievement
but only the corner of is shown heads
thank you go away please all right so I
need to go up to the comm center
oh sure it loud in here following hazard
you say Oh what kind of well are we
talking about here this is loud minor
perforation area u4 u5 bendin pressures
loose is locked s3 I don't know one of
those mean down for a hundred and forty
three days okay but why well I mean I
think I know why but why I have so many
questions so many questions okay hello I
don't know if I
I was gonna come down here anyway the
Ames is guiding me oh dami a son of a
[ __ ] oh you're such a sack of [ __ ] oh
oh oh oh oh oh hi dissipated early for a
monster don't you think I haven't even
barely gotten into the game just uh some
piece I'm / you keep wandering over
there I'm gonna sneak up behind you
so maybe nobody ok I think we're okay it
came from through here
damn it is loud and ok it's much better
over here what oh god it's a dead end
oh why did I come down here yeah yeah
alrighty then
what do I have to run through that I'll
probably die I need to turn them wait
Oh oh crap I see it okay I see it I need
to turn away oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy I do what do I do
hello idiot it's probably gonna kill me
cause it's definitely gonna kill me Oh
death yes okay okay
Oh ow
my ankles oh I don't think I did
anything with that I accomplished very
little in my adventure all I did was
break my ankles many times over okay
oh that's not good
oh crap I'm not doing good at all
Oh alrighty then goodbye sir and Kurt oh
hey I survived the monster I didn't die
a horrible horrible death but men again
maybe he was coming to give me a hug
maybe there's all big misunderstanding
and they're all just lovey-dovey robot
creatures a little too lovey-dovey if
you can dump them all the oil everywhere
looky
so who was that Amy and Karl pathos
buddies okey-dokey then
all right so where am i okay I'm in
communications a circle there no maybe
I'm not I just went upstairs so I'm
assuming I'm in the communications area
oh no you are here right there it says
right there it's stupid okay so I need
to get to the communications which
should be just right over here and
obviously someone has been living here
for quite a while Oh
you
Oh
oh oh okay oh oh good oh oh oh that's
not fun okay I'm glad I get to listen to
nad for a while now I didn't want to go
near it in case it was actually gonna
like grab me and kill me I have no idea
if that's what it was actually gonna do
but holy hell this looks like a hiding
place oh my god what happened to you
look um he's dead thanks dad is dead so
this is Carl
this is the real Carl anyway did he get
the final backup turbos going much as we
possibly can
no that's it enough power to run paint
on Stu until the next apocalypse we're
ready to go that's so weird that's so
weird I was like I was I couldn't think
of anything to actually say that was
clever during that point maybe in case
you couldn't tell what was going on that
robot was this guy I don't know I think
I have no idea
that was weird oh that was weird fada
turn around we sealed Upsilon to keep it
working don't [ __ ] it up hey Zorro card
was not my Carl was not my fault okay Oh
turn around
no oh nevermind turn around oh no okay I
thought it was gonna be a little bit of
a hint hint there but apparently not
yeah that robot was weird oh my god that
was so weird yeah I remember there was
some
there was some like preview videos that
they put out like over a year ago
nas Braulio that was bright idea when
there's water leaking out of it I don't
think I want to actually open that
Zeppelin cargo transfer yeah
mind your head no mine is gonna be a
little you know I think I get what
you're getting at
oh so weird so weird
hello Lazaro Amy okay so as our Oh Amy
did something to Carl but now I have her
key card which is good I suppose
something's very wrong going on here and
I don't much like it
I'm really trying to process my thoughts
because what I was saying before is said
there were these preview videos that
kind of showed that this the one was
called Mockingjay or something like that
Mockingbird ooh are you gonna be Amy I
have no idea but it was a robot that
somehow to personality of another person
on the station and had like memories of
them and legitimately thought it was the
person it was mimicking which was really
weird really weird I'm gonna touch you
okay good great okay all fun all fun so
it's fun there's so much fun going on oh
man so glad everything's happening the
exact weight it is is close that door so
someone is fighting it I almost forgot
about you okay so it was I was I
supposed to talk with you you okay hey
can you hear me hello
Hey
I didn't want to go near you I didn't
even know I could like talk to you
hello oh here we go I do 735 okay
Oh 735 so obviously Oh 735 and oh seven
to two oh seven three five and oh seven
to two so those are the ideas that I
need oh seven 3507 too - all right oh
seven three five okay all right
male managed to link most back up turbos
bad news machines are getting worse we
try to come up with a way to shut them
all down but considering the same amount
of Units ooh okay good job try to get
the backup turbos cut production robots
are getting increasingly erratic all
over pathos - and unfortunately there's
no Universal kill switch seeing how we
won't - man our manager insufficient
power
oh shut down one of the highlights
section to divert power to the
communication center I know what you
need me to do okay I know what I need
did I know I know I'm gonna hang on but
before I'll be right back
I'm gonna log in to the other guy right
here oh seven two two Carl sempkin
maximum capacity event log turbine
overheat uh power output okay that's not
good so I know what I need to do so I
didn't need to do this I needed to I
just didn't know that I need to do and I
didn't get a chance to actually talk
with him to try it in
I forgot the closer
that does not make me feel okay that
does not make me feel good
okay all righty then okay I don't have
enough power for that but I did get oh
there we go
okay I got three of them on and I also
got this open whoo
is there something good in here is it
gonna get me away from the screams
because those are gonna haunt my dreams
for a long time
see crv seven black box precision
instrument designed to observe your
overall condition and meaning it
measures a wide range of data this
information is constantly relied the
pathos to warden unit station can
provide out oh okay so I know what this
is this is the scans your brain and it
keeps backups and it puts them into
weird robots I don't think I want to put
that in my brain why would I want to do
that ouki alrighty then and that's
awfully big to be putting in your brain
I mean my brains big no space left in
there
okay
there was another closed door over here
right okay this one so then get in a
flow control I should be able to do
something else that I need to do we
strain the system if you pull the lever
there's no turning back make sure you
want it bad enough Oh what do I want I
don't know what I want how about you
know what I want I barely know what I'm
doing how would I be able to make any
decision like that I don't think I can
open up this area but I did provide
power to one more section than I want to
inspect before I actually do that I'm
pretty sure that I need to do that
anyway but I want to make sure that I
know exactly what I'm doing so I should
have I should have done power oh God so
I should be able to go up here now so I
don't know if I'm source to throw the
switch for flow control I'm gonna close
that keep me away from things
okay oh all right good
the office is closing down everyone's
being evacuated honor working with
everyone update on defense global
community to prevent collision has
failed what
21:03 in January what the hell it is
with great sadness I have to inform you
that the office will close supervisor
jane addams turn the group
what happened
some sort of impact what was it like an
asteroid coming or something loom our
link broken manual input required I
don't know what this is okay uh theta
let me try theta
oh hello I'm alone here
okay Josie we got everything we need to
learn but I can't leave the platform
Supervision Adams decided to leave Amy
asada become something to execute the
optimization process and I'm better
thrilled about it I just wanted to let
you know we're on schedule I'll talk to
you tomorrow it will do I wanted to
introduce you to a Liam cow they'll be
doing the talking as soon as are you
later
say hello Peter stressed and dispatcher
out there just let me know
I suppose that's it I'll see you real
soon why we all right Jones me have a
safe trip hey hello Beta Epsilon
what's up we could really use direct
contact with Heather I mean site service
engineer will check the reg links are
almost impossible to establish the
Llumar relays are basically junk at this
you could send messages by the comm
center of it do you want to pretty much
always here
they'd either be a anything my hand I
know it's a shitty system but it's all
it works right yeah all right we just
have to make to catch you later hello
Peter with it I'm here what's up we're
getting out
want to tell you that I'm going to steal
the Compson announcer this is definitely
the last you'll hear from us if we don't
show up in the next couple of hours
the calorie its don't say plant ID
yeah go ahead for the shuttle arrived
directly to theta okay good I'll not
leave the troops for a local place like
the okay I'm trying to keep track of
everything and I'm trying to make sure
that I will hello oh thank you ah that
felt good
I'm glad I got inside my brain Hey Wow
it doesn't hurt anymore after I broke my
ankle
hahahaha okay all right let's try I'm
already at epsilon so I might as well
try it
oh whatever yeah to 203
let's go lambda come on where yeah oh
yeah baby
where's that sweet spot I'm gotcha hey I
found the dome ceiling hey that's better
hey Simon was it Jaron Simon Gerry hi
common I'm Katherine have you figured
out what's going on yet me I was hoping
you'd have some answers I probably have
done what do you want to know where do
you even begin I mean what is this place
how did I get here and why do the robots
talk like they're people
well here at Oh Kalon clearly have you
never been there before where did you
work the grimoire in Toronto is that
really important no I mean where did you
what to pay those two I don't know what
that is that's unexpected did you come
directly from Toronto yeah I did and it
was very unexpected have you seen any
people like staff or field technicians
only robots crazy ones except for one
eye I think he was in pain I'm not sure
what to do he said he was good sort of I
don't know I think this place is about
to collapse
what do I do
I need to go I guess really
okay I guess I'm dying now that's cool I
had a lot of other places that I wanted
to communicate with before that happened
oh well I guess I'll just lips were
quiet swatch quietly interview miss oh
I'm alive I needed I can't move okay
can't move what a minute
what the hell how is this possible oh oh
I had a sneaking suspicion that I might
be a Robo Bobo bot because you know
that's what happens when you need a
robot you just do robot II things like
you're able to somehow wake up in the
middle of us a facility wait Oh what I
can't swim
what am I too heavy with my robot body
okay yeah I'm definitely a robot almost
I'll never sound definitely a robot but
then again what is a robot the weird
definitions kind of betray me at this
point
I have no idea what's going on ah it's
still cool oh I scare so cool this game
is so cool I'm really really enjoying
myself here because one I have no idea
what's going on which is amazing when I
go into one of these games that I
actually have no idea what's going on
I'm coming up with all kinds of theories
but I'm afraid that I'm gonna be wrong
so I don't want to say it out loud just
yet give me a few more fun shout over
laughs ah yeah give me a few more
episodes then I'll actually figure out
what I'm doing but for some reason I
went from present-day too far in the
future of the Year 2103
my name is Simon but I appeared inside a
facility where everything was locked
down and everyone else is dead which
means that I am one of these weird
bizarre infected robots and the other
robots when they talk to me they
wouldn't have been able to tell that
anything was weird because
they think they're human or something
like that so with all that being said
I'm now wandering this facility where
apparently they were trying to prevent a
catastrophe of some sort of like
asteroid impact and I don't know why
they were doing that underwater maybe
they were just trying to create like you
know an ark for survival but something
seems to have gone very wrong and
everyone seems to be dying because these
robots are coming from who knows where
to do who knows what and why it's all
happening is it'd be even bigger mystery
than what I was trying to ponder before
so to be honest and to cut it short I
have no idea what's going on and I'm
afraid to say what I think I say because
I know I'm probably wrong but god this
games cool it's so cool it's so cool oh
hello okay a little bizarre a little
bizarre I mean the game is obviously all
about very much about the mind and what
is a mind and what is life like probably
I imagine that the question that they're
trying to ponder or put in front of you
is the idea let me get this you better
answer me stress key come on Amy we're
wearing heels I at least call with you
it always helped hold on you got the
power automated right there put the plan
to shame we need the power to keep the
sites running assassin tower just rusty
she's killed Carl oh [ __ ] all right up
come on down and it'll be okay
get back the bigger yes I think so I'll
head to the shell of the ox coming at me
waiting for you
okay
the idea that they're probably trying to
address is kind of a thought question
you know kind of like it a thought
experiment where if you took the mind
like the mind as you know it or brain as
you know it or everything that makes up
consciousness as you know it and you
took it out of a human body and you put
it into something else and replaced all
of its inputs to try to convince it that
it was anything but what it was wouldn't
know wouldn't know anything was
different what a human taken out of a
human body I'm underwater why am I
worried about sound but if you took
everything that made a human human
that's in its mind but put it somewhere
else and replace some inputs would it
ever know that anything was wrong like
or could you replicate a human mind so
well that it was indistinguishable from
what was making a human human but it's
in a robot body and its motives are
ulterior and it doesn't even know of
it's lying or it's lying and you don't
know if it's lying like it's a lot of
thought experiments that have been
questioned throughout time and wondering
hey okay that's probably not good hello
so there's a lot of questions to address
in terms of like not ethics but in like
oh I forget what the words like like you
know philosophy philosophy that's it
it's like a philosophical experiment in
terms of what makes us us and I mean
there's even a theory like you know we
we all could be brains in jars in some
off place and this could all be just a
construct like the matrix just a theory
that's spread out and no one would know
how would anyone know does this hello
little buddy
should I free you probably not you have
a gun - the gun don't shoot me
well alright then thank you I guess okay
bye
am I supposed to follow you I doubt it I
can't even swim right cuz I'm a robot
Hey but it's cool right it's really cool
right I've been like dying to play this
game by the way in case you guys
couldn't tell I'm the super sir hello
are you following me I'm super super
excited about this I'm like I'm been
waiting for this game for a long time
one because personal games makes great
games but also they tell good stories
what the hell did you just bonk into
that thing
what's wrong with you are you drunk
probably but I probably shouldn't go
towards you what are you doing
you're just bunking into that thing over
and over again
I think you might have a bit of a
problem sir and I probably shouldn't be
near you if anything to judge by the
horrible music okay so I gotta get in
there somehow there's got to be a way up
or around or something oh okay
I think I'm still supposed to just
follow the path I mean I probably was
supposed to walk right behind that thing
and it was gonna oh hey God what is with
you weirdos like I don't know if I'm
actually supposed to be worried about
you ki
I don't know how am I supposed to know
thanks a little buddy I like you
Oh a name you tiny sub Jim
damn it's gone I gotta be more original
than that I can't just name him Tim I
can't name everything Tim uh I'm gonna
name you bubble butt cuz I like you cuz
you you shoot bubbles out your button I
like that
so bubble butt are you gonna follow me
in the ear you just gonna be wandering
around here forever
cuz you're my only friend at this point
I don't even trust that lady come on
bubble butt you wanna come into a bubble
boats all excited hey
oh okay both of us sure is nice like a
bubble but helping me out
thanks bubble butt oh man he's just the
best I love you and you're bubbly but
tells this am I supposed to do something
about that oh okay well it's bubble
buddy okay
oh thanks bubble bud bye have a good
time bubble butt
I'll see you around hopefully hopefully
bring him back I like bubble butt
Bobo's adorable come on no more no more
come on there we go no don't close all
right okay so this is like the first
uh-oh
maybe I should close this door Ben come
on Bessie burp
okay there we go good enough swipe
omni-tool maybe the boat bah bah bah bah
yay okay I need it
oh my ears quite loud thank you you can
stop now I can't move
loading a little bit oh and it got quiet
let's up the shuttle still work I don't
even know why I would well I am gonna go
in there in the next video so thank you
everybody so much for watching there's
so many questions that I have in my mind
I'm so excited about what's in the
future but I don't want to get ahead of
myself just because I don't know
everything contrary to popular belief I
don't know everything so thank you
everybody someone for watching i'm gonna
continue playing very soon
remember there's gonna be new videos in
this every single day probably the same
time every day for until it's done so
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video
ah